It's the final ps+ update of the year a
bunch of games are coming to the extra
and premium tiers of PlayStation Plus on
December 19th just in time to ignore
your family at Christmas I'll show you
gameplay from everything coming your way
and your job is to tell us all what you
plan to play I'm adamaru hello there
please think about dropping a like if
the series is useful to you let's start
with ps+ extra first up we have a Final
Fantasy game no not that one and no not
that one either this is Final Fantasy
origin stranger of paradise an action
RPG designed to be an alternative
version of the original Final Fantasy
game from almost 40 years ago on the NES
we play as Jack and explore fight and
follow his unquenched desire to destroy
the chaos that fills this land realtime
combat is present with the usual Final
Fantasy tropes of mixing physical and
magical attacks to break the enemy but
this was also inspired by Dark Souls
where timing matters and many enemies
genuinely pose a threat to Jack's
survival once an enemy is depleted
enough Jack can perform a soul burst
which really adds to the power fantasy
after a tough battle story-wise there
are some cringeworthy moments and the
story in the first few hours makes no
sense at all but to my surprise every
story beat is pulled together at the end
and it works stranger of paradise has
online multiplayer and the average
review score is about 7.5 out of 10 will
you give it a go next hot on the
announcement of GTA 6 comes GTA 5 I'm
guessing you've played this on multiple
platforms by now in fact has anyone not
play GTA 5 at this point before you skip
forward if you haven't tried the PS5
version yet it's worth it and a great
chance to see the updated visuals the
higher frame rates and the crazy fast
loading times the single player story
follows the three protagonists we all
know and love an old bank robber a
street Thug and a legendary Gunrunner
and once that Adventure concludes the
open world of online mult M player is
here with more missions to fight through
more illegal businesses to run and more
online trolls than you ever thought
possible maybe it is time to get the
squad back together for one last Heist a
game I've been longing to try is metal
hell singer a rhythm-based firstperson
shooter it's like Guitar Hero mixed with
doom we are part demon and must find our
Vengeance in the depths of hell as we
play a heavy metal soundtrack can be
heard and we must try and time our shots
to hit the beat and slay the minions of
hell this builds a combo which unlocks
more rewards powering up weapons ready
for the boss fights Rhythm games deserve
more love promise me you'll try this
Metacritic 78% Souls like brothers and
sisters your game of the month is salt
and sacrifice playing as an Inquisitor
we Dodge parry and slash our way through
countless foes and don't be fooled by
the Retro art style Salton sacrifice is
challenging like its Souls like kin
speaking of the Retro appeal there are
many Metroid Vania mechanic mechanics at
work with Out Of Reach upgrades in sight
early on yet you'll need to return later
in the game to actually acquire them a
multiplayer mode is here if you need
someone to hold your hand and share the
danger salt and sacrifice review score
73 out of 100 another game this month
with a very similar Vibe is Moon scars
another Metroid Adventure title with
retro Graphics Moon scars is less
challenging in combat but adds
precarious platforming to keep players
on their toes in fact inside the hellish
Castle this becomes was almost a one for
one Castlevania game great for the
lovers of that series reviewers say it's
a 71 out of 100 and wait there's another
one this is Grime a single player Souls
like with metroidvania elements as we
fight our way across the land we learn
about the history of this planet where
we actually are in the solar system and
the enormous ramifications of being here
Grime is Elusive and that Enigma is the
glue that keeps players coming back not
many review scores out there but IGN
gave it a 9 out of 10 speaking of of
hellish Vistas Moto gp23 is your sports
game of the month step into the shoes of
your favorite professional Rider and
compete on perfectly accurate tracks to
be crowned Moto GP Champion Dynamic
weather adds to the realism and will
cause even the most veteran of riders to
fall if attention isn't paid to the wet
and windy conditions a local split
screen mode is here and online
multiplayer is fully supported okay
let's lift this mood take a look at Mega
Man 11 on the PS4 the action platformer
starring the from Smash Bros in a modern
take on the 2D classic platformer series
Mega Man is renowned for the gameplay
Loop hasn't really changed the Mega
Buster is here but there are some new
abilities the speed gun and the power
gear the speed gun lets Mega Man slow
down time whereas the power gear
increases the power of His Weaponry
pretty simple nothing here is breaking
the Mega Man mold if you played the
previous games this will keep you happy
Metacritic 82% take a look at gigabash
this is a brawler in this cartoony art
style we control a guu and and beat The
Living Daylights out of other players
and AI around giant cities fully
destructible cities gameplay Wise It's a
total free-for-all button bashing or
more considered fighting styles are
permitted the carrot on the stick is to
keep playing for the unlocks new guy
become available regularly Metacritic 73
out of 100 next a game I had no idea
existed tiny kin Milo arrives on Earth
to find that he's way too small
everybody's gone and not a day has
passed since 1991 we team up with the
mysterious tiny kin and use their unique
powers to create ladders Bridges and
explode a bunch of things a single
player platform Puzzler from 2022 with
an average review score of 8 out of 10
any fellow old people here have a look
at prodius a game which describes itself
as a boomer shooter a first-person
shooter taking inspiration from classic
doom and Unreal Tournament a handcrafted
campaign by industry veterans is here
with Co-op and competitive multiplayer
modes there's also a Creator mode to
build and share your own Maps Boomer
Shooters are the future right okay onto
your RPG for the month this is Shadow
run Returns on the PS4 and PS5 a
tactical RPG using this isometric
Viewpoint aside from bullets there is an
extensive social system at play with
interactions just as important as guns
roles include Shadow Runner mercenaries
Mages hackers this is a proper little
RPG and on the back of that there are
more Shadow Run games dragonfall and
Hong Kong are here too a Trilogy of
tactical RPGs to take over your life
dragonfall is more focused on branching
storytelling with many different
outcomes whereas Hong Kong acts as an
epilog to the original story will you
jump into the extensive world of
Shadowrun games it's now the part of the
video where games are removed from the
catalog and this time we know games that
will be leaving in January as well as
December this week you'll lose access to
the sublime shadow of M and Shadow Of
War Two Yakuza games are going away like
a dragon and Yakuza 6 and it's also your
last chance to play Friday the 13th
before that game shuts down forever
other games going this week are The
Escapist 2 El foreclosed caladrius Blaze
Damascus gear and legends of ethernal
it's also last calls on a bunch of games
leaving in just over a month giving you
plenty of time to finish the stories or
get the elusive platinum trophy mid
January 2024 we'll see Devil May Cry and
its special edition depart as well as it
takes two which is by far and away the
perfect Christmas game for a family
night if you can put up with your family
that long jet the far Shore leaves in
January as does omo the missing JJ
macfield and the island of memories
mitsurugi kamway haai sorry for that
pronunciation pillars of Eternity 2 and
the strangely brilliant snowrunner I
think I prefer knowing which games are
leaving over a month before they do very
helpful I hope this wasn't a mistake and
this becomes standard practice oky doie
over to the premium games for the month
13 of them this time around let me
explain your first shot of retro
goodness is the Mega Man Legacy
Collection and the Mega Man Legacy
Collection too 10 games in total the
8bit era of the iconic little dude
consists of Mega Man 1 to six and that's
where the second package picks up taking
us beyond the 8bit era and into 16 and
32bit worlds of Mega Man 7 8 9 and 10
and of course there was Mega Man 11
earlier in the video that's 11 Mega Man
action Platformers this month I hope you
like Mega Man also on premium this month
is Thrillville and Thrillville off the
rails a theme park Creator from back in
the PSP and PS2 days and to finish the
whole month off is Buzz Light Year of
Star Command man I feel old so that is
your month please sound off in the
comments is ps+ living up to your
expectations I'd love to know your
thoughts I'm Adam you're awesome Merry
Christmas see you next
time